pronti per the forest e regala cazzo
fuori non vanno non è che gli ha tirato
il fuoco
no no se egli non la gente di più
cazzo cazzo occhiata sesso non doveva
accendere il fuoco merda mentre loro
girano a caso vado a dormire spero che
non mi controlli no spero di no
davanti a tutti i ragazzi ragazze e
bellissimo come i piccioni sto gioco
rimangono sospesi a mezz'aria senza
motivo karmica mi fa una paura star
stile di notte né una verità comunque
nome scazzo la merda di fuoco il pavia
ricordi ecco perfetto che faceva vediamo
di fare una eccola qui è un po grossa mi
ricorda che per tesi da che parte dove
metterla di preciso ragazzi non so un
cazzo di ste cose mi fa piacere però
devo provarci perché sono finiscono
nella merda mi qui va bene anche se non
sto bene confronti criterio sento di m
ma va bene così riesco a tagliare due o
tre alberi senza che mi arrivi gente che
rompe i [ __ ] cosa molto probabile a
ragazzi voglio fare sta cosa come avevo
detto prima e poi voglio se riesco mi
servirebbe andare di nuovo nella caverna
quella di una quella che era andato nel
nostro servizio perché di comprendere il
flare quello con la pistola la
maledizione grado di avere tutto
abbiamo anche una trappola della madonna
vediamo se riesco si è perfetto ragazzi
alla ragazza abbia una trappola della
madonna abbiamo un fuoco che brucia solo
me stesso prova bene ti se manca chi
cazzo questo tizio gara c'è un tizio c'è
un tizio un po bello qui sotto ma
affanculo non muore case di salve
ragazzi c'è un tizio che a terra che
credo sia nostro amico ma io ve lo
lascio qui va bene che può bastare sta
roba che ho fatto che ho costruito la
cappa vento abbastanza decente
spero di veder si rischia di andare a
fare quello che volevo fare dall'inizio
riuscirà a trovare la caverna rega
quella dove dove vi avevano intrappolato
nello scorso episodio a credo che sia
dintorni per comunque prime non può che
mi chiedo altro c'è una lucertola
nell'inventario non chiedetemi bevo l'ho
presa da morello anche di fare quindi
almeno ricordo per cucinare ragazzi a
farsi un cazzo di fuoco però è tipo
perché non ci sono le cucine un soldato
è notato questo dovrebbe essere un posto
abbastanza decente
eccola qui finché lo posso subito la
amica mia tu ti sei presentato al
momento giorno cazzo coniglio che va a
fuoco
porca [ __ ] scusa ragazzi hanno dato
fuoco coniglia senza monetine ucciso uno
e sono sono usciti vabbè lasciamo
perdere ancora i conigli che vanno a
fuoco basta è una cosa ma che a caso
frega lega perché cadono conigli morti
nostra collina ragazzi non ho mai capito
come cazzola abbiano fatto stick conigli
a cadere dalla collina ma non importa
andiamo a mangiare prima che muoia di
fame perché comica sono a secco di
cucinare un coniglio almeno è però hai
rotto i [ __ ] caso non è colpa mia se
con ivana poco ok io ci provo però non
lo so se numero che passano pronti a un
fuoco che non sono il grido fuoco
un'edizione e poi mi senti in colpa ma
l'inter ma non è colpa mia è colpa loro
saranno sul fuoco mio dio mentre si
cuoce il coniglio cosa molto normale la
gente comune guarda la tv magari io no
io vado in giro nelle foreste
porco tutto porti a trojan ha visto
invece [ __ ] ragazzi rega veloci il
coniglio e coniglio veloce ma mangia
mangia in fretta come dicevamo anche
abbracciato la stronza che non sia brava
indietreggia così brava brutta [ __ ]
ragazze c'è una con le proprie di fuori
che tenta di di stuprarmi ma noi ce la
farà perché sono superiori
io me ne vado via dico prima che
qualcuno tenti di dimetterlo dove non
dovrebbe neanche fare due passi senza
che la gente che ti salti addosso come
se niente fosse cerchio su scappano
questi c'è la gente che scappa la mia
originale detti sciacalli che cazzo
avete fatto a mio rifugio loro mi hanno
spento il fuoco bravi grazie molto
gentili si rischia cosa ho fatto
premuto ho creato un martello allora
anche la molotov posso fare questa merda
e lo sapevo se cazzo si luci direi
fossero posso dar fuoco a voi bastardi
erano ragazzi non ci posso credere che
si possono non lo sapevo perché anzi c'è
un martello della madonna avrebbe
approvate le si avvicina valori di
stronzi di merda per casa sapete dov'è
andato a finire la pizza con le poppe
vorrei fargli assaggiare il mio martello
niente doppi sensi
da quando ho lasciato il fatto che
potrei ancora acceso mi hanno spento
quella l'accampamento ma questa è acceso
non si sa perché è meglio andare piano
prima che qualcuno qua finisca ma ecco
per fa infatti c'è gente laggiù che cosa
fanno davanti alla aereo loro hanno
esercitato per fare le hostess però non
lo so io me ne vado per sicurezza perchè
non mi piacciono e posto è ecco quella
sì l'ho trovata che funziona la torcia
si è funzionata ragazzi o alla torcia
fortunatamente con la batteria che non
so quanto potrà durare ma va bene così
tanto ok perfetto trovato le asce che
rimangono sospese ma non facciamoci
l'oman
allora andiamo avanti ragazzi vogliono
trovare benissimo
partiamo da dio avete visto anche voi
[Musica]
quanto cazzo era quel colosso che è
andato sopra il suo film babe lasciamo
perdere i bug che sono l'ultimo dei miei
problemi buongiorno amica via ragazzi
c'è il c'è una tipa molto sexy che vi
sta guardando ma questa è la strada che
avevo preso l'altra volta non mi pagano
questa e un'altra ancora quanti cazzo di
strade ci sono perché c'è una luce la
giochi casa fatto sto fuoco lei è per
caso di qui a una torcia a una torcia
anche lui non si sa come ma ce l'ha
ancora capito dove stiamo andando di
precisione credo di essere nel posto
giusto amico ad una sega di dov'era il
punto dell'altra volta ma non importa
andiamo avanti lo stesso cosa cazzo sono
quei cosi amici obiettivi sculaccione si
deve perché sei un tizio morto e capi
come non detto ragazzi non ho ben capito
che cosa sono sti cosi qui che ballano
ma lascialo perdere andiamo avanti nel
dubbio che bug della madonna dove sono
finito è una cosa pazzesca è una
catenina salve no no no no no no no no
kat
no no no no no no no no no no non allora
non avete capito una sega noto ed all
iti lui da baldry cieco dove ritiene cha
cha sta certo quel punto e pagatissimo
quindi non ci tenevano andarci lo stesso
va bene così dovrebbe essere
ecco la ragazza ho trovato a cazzo si
perfetto marfan ce l'abbiamo
torniamo a casa subito ce l'abbiamo
fatta regalo ce l'abbiamo è stata che è
stata la cosa più disturbante della mia
vita per noi non c'è non ci tornerò mai
più un cazzo di caverna sappiatelo
intende non far esplorare come come sta
messa sa isola perché ancora non possa
chiazzo era qualcosa
in ultimo vedere se riesco c'è un tizio
lo zio qui prendere io io mi avvicino
lascia un attimo l'avviso la prima
vicino questa roba perché finisce male
io te lo dico se provi ad attaccarmi
soltanto un attimo team filo questa roba
dritta stupri ma me lo sei un uomo era
una gamba scusatemi falso allarme ho
scambiato una gamba per un uomo mi
dispiace che quel questo è un uomo
effettivamente [ __ ] ok ragazzi io
vorrei fare una precisazione allora io
io non so se voi vedete quello che sto
vedendo io però io sto vedendo del cazzo
di pesci che nuotano nell'aria
ditemi se è normale non posso neanche
beccarli questi pesci bellissima cammini
chilometri di minchia di pali che
spuntano a casa della zia
magari non vorrei conoscerla solo il suo
parrucchiere però di sicuro è meglio del
mio ma non ci vuole molto buono se
roccia bastardo brozzo ragazzi gli ho
dato fuoco funziona sta merda se ci ha
messo mezz'ora andarla a prendere ma ne
è valsa la pena via vieni qui media
riguardati le mani [ __ ] scappa farmi
un cazzo cazzo come non farsi notare in
un'isola piena di cannibali non stai
facendo giusto allora io adesso voglio
trovare un cazzo di punto dove mettermi
a posto senza che mi ha visto [ __ ]
però amico mio tema fuoco alcuno non so
se stessa cosa porca [ __ ] devi morire
bruciati morto così gli ho dato fuoco
due volte ragazzi non muore
non è possibile iniziando ad aver freddo
di trovare una minchia di riparlerà
villoso sono nella me perché poi questi
si avrà chiamato di sicuro rinforzi poi
non è che passa inosservato uno che va a
fuoco dal culo mezzo alla foresta quindi
sono nella merda dobbiamo tornare al
rifugio lega fatemi tornare a quel cazzo
di rifugio anche se ci mettiamo
tornare du riusciti cos'è via al rifugio
per oggi e cosa ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qui questo episodio che è che
è durato anni perché ci ho messo ora per
girare per tutta l'isola pedonale di
continuare nel prossimo comunque ragazzi
se il vino è piaciuto una solito ha
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovate nella descrizione del sele
prestiti iscrivetevi ci vediamo il
prossimo video belle ragazze